hi
i'm andy i'm 39 years old i live in wood
green with my girlfriend kate
and our two kids cherry and ollie and
their twins they
in their slightly deluded way think i'm
the world's strongest man
i tell them frequently that that's not
me and points to eddie hall going
i'd like to be stronger for them
can i make you're all right nice to meet
you andy how you doing tommy
how are you feeling about yourself right
now uh hoping that by the end of six
weeks i'll be kind of similar size to
you
i've got a team with me got luke and
chris with peace to each other no end so
we know how to beast people
first up i'm gonna get luke to take your
body fats yeah and how tall are you andy
five foot two it's the thickest beer
i've had
[Music]
what's with all the the piercings and
the tattoos yeah i used to be very much
into like the body mod world
piercing body mod body modification say
titanium piercings
i've been suspended through hooks
through my skin you put nails for you
and stuff not quite
brush and easy
[Music]
more than what you said
[Music]
so you're basically to be shoulder
pressing one of your kids we're good for
you at your concerts we'll pick one hand
[Music]
come on let's hold the jug mate come on
come on that's it let's mark that down
at 10 meters
come on more requests get down faster
tell you what i still have a bad time
nice and bad
all we need from you now is a before
picture yeah and then in six weeks time
you can look back at it and have a bit
of giggle to herself
face me let's do a double bicep pose
[Music]
beautiful super impressed man
you've done really well so luke and
chris will devise your diet plan
your training regime and if you stick to
it i can guarantee you'll come back in
six weeks
i'm gonna see a different guy looking
forward to it yeah very much i'll put it
there man
i'm not i'm not convinced that he's
going to go away and put the work in
you know he did everything last night
today but i just think the attitude of
like you know i really want this
i'm going to get it done you can get the
fire wasn't quite there for me might
just be a slow burning we're gonna go
get a pizza yeah right
it's been a good day guys
so i've done my gym session had my food
watched the first
episode of season 10 of the walking dead
priorities
[Music]
looking forward to a weekend with the
family celebrating my kid's birthday
just
need to try and ignore whatever food
they're eating
so they got sushi big load of sushi i
really wanted it
i really wanted it
[Music]
they had chicken nuggets with what
seemed to be about a billion chips
i love chips i'm not gonna lie
hey andy i've been following your
progress and it looks like you've been
smashing it i'm sending chris and luke
to check up on you
give you some support big love the beast
[Music]
hey dude you're right yeah you're right
yeah good
[Music]
how much weight did you lose on the
first week
i think it was about four kilos he gets
a tiny bit grumpy
is he having any of the things that you
have so say you have some chips
did he have any yes did he i noticed the
the suspension pictures yeah as well how
did how did that come about basically a
lot of it's adrenaline endorphins yeah
you know you get to a certain point
where that can wear off yeah and then it
starts getting a bit uncomfortable said
okay you know really heavy guys go up
have you ever seen anybody as heavy as
me
red probably not as heavy as your head
now but you know
you're kind of a different thing
altogether really
so the fact that he slipped up in the
first half is he going to do it again
and is he going to do it even more
i don't know
i've got a goal and i need to get there
i don't know if the kid's proud i don't
want them to
see the end of this six weeks and go
well danny had this chance
but couldn't we be bothered
[Music]
andy how you doing buddy hey dude how
are you you're right yeah i'm good man
you're looking well all the exercises
that we gave you to go away and work on
i think one of your worst was the front
carry the grip
week by week i've been trying to up the
weight on that to
try and improve it my grip would be at
least
marginally better than when we when i
came to see you because it was like 10
meters
rubbish wow well this is what it's all
about this is about
us bringing you in sending you away
getting your beastie coming back
and showing improvement i just want to
say keep it up buddy keep your chin up
high keep listening to that heavy rock
and i'll see you in a few weeks and
hopefully we've got a bit a bit more
muscle on you and you've lost a bit of
flab around your belly as well
that's it andy's one of the ones who
left the mansion with the biggest
question mark over his head
i can't quite gauge him you know uh it's
easy to say things but to actually do
them is a different thing i suppose time
will tell
i started to feel a little bit of
pressure now i want to
get to the end and for my kids to go dad
you look awesome
[Applause]
hello
[Music]
it's okay how's it going i've had to
deal with the uh
the hungriness do you think that your
daddy is still the strongest one in the
world
he's the strongest probably the
strongest dad in the world
[Music]
what's the result saying guys really
impressed with this so we've got just
over six and a half kilos gone
and six percent body fat loss percent
body fat loss
wow that's one of the best we've had
yeah really good
all right now
the point for
here we are with your nemesis here all
we got last time was we got one length
let's go
how the hell did you go from 10 meters
to nearly 90. how do you do that
um wizardry is too big how many percent
improvement is that
900 improvements like heller we've got
one more feet of strength
and that's to take your top off and
there's cold weather that's fine so we
can get
after picture of the before picture andy
does the honors buddy
what do you see different definitely
slimmer he's lost weight around his
tummy his hips
his chest and his face his face is
slimmer as well
big smile man absolutely phenomenal work
really good are you proud of your dad
why would i not be
i mean you've got every reason to be
proud
there you go and you said one of your
ambitions was to pick your kids up and
put them on your shoulders for concert
both of them yeah
that seems a bit much i think there's
still a long way to go from anywhere
close to being the world's strongest man
or reaching any of eddie's records
at least to my kids i continue to still
be the world's strongest dad to them
i'm going to keep pushing to try and get
stronger and stronger as they get bigger
i actually had my doubts about andy you
know when we met him
he just seemed a bit too out there you
know a bit spaced out
but you know i mean my words right now
he's gone away he's put the work in
and i you know i genuinely believe that
his family has been
his inspiration he's definitely been
beasted that's for sure he came to get
beasted and he got
you